hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
today is Thursday we're back with
another warriors then recap stream we
got some interesting news to talk about
with the new content of the week as well
as a new different type of order and
apollyon is the legacy event new
testamental week 3 some stuff has been
changed so let's get started with that
we're really quick before we get into
the info I just want to mention you guys
are gonna be hearing some background
music I've put that recently in some of
my videos more and more often I'm trying
to start adding some more lo-fi hip-hop
some chill vibes in the background a lot
of people who seem to enjoy my chillness
so I thought I'd match it with the chill
vibe music hopefully you guys do enjoy
that if you do tell me in the comments
below if not I can always find a
different song and tell me it's just
like I said tell me your opinion on that
I'd really love to hear it but in other
words that's over with let's actually
get into the news for today
so first up test your metal 3 has been
released this is the last final week for
the tester metal so if you have one all
the other two might as well go for the
third and get all the winds the emblem
you're gonna be getting for the the
tester metal three is gonna be on screen
right now once again not really big on
emblems myself but who knows maybe
you'll enjoy it one of the changes
coming to test your mettle 3 is going to
be the fact that you're going to be
fighting only the bosses as opposed to
or what it originally was was only
fighting the factions so now the bosses
are if you don't know apollyon Goodman
da sage or oh and Emperor Tosun those
are going to be the four bosses you have
to fight and they're gonna it's going to
be the same every single time they are
of course gonna get harder this is the
third week so it's just gonna be like
last week but now you're only going to
be fighting bosses instead of just the
bosses and then they're respected
teammates you can also choose which type
of version you want to play your test
your Medellin if you want to go to back
to the first week or the second week if
you want to get the emblem rewards for
those I'm assuming you can do or if you
just want to play the third one that's
completely up to you and as well the
maps are also going to have some
fireworks going off in the background
which is kind of cool I didn't really I
didn't really notice when I played but
they are they're the new content of a
week our mythic outfits and they're only
going to be unlockable from March 8th
and they're going to be costing 15000
steel and they're gonna be called house
champions with a firework effect for
different factions so we're gonna play
that video right now and I'll see you
when that's over
[Music]
so that's going to be the mythic outfit
with its respected faction effect I
think it looks pretty cool I definitely
like the Knights one the samurai ones
cause well actually all of them are
pretty nice in my opinion definitely
gonna be grabbing that a fellow YouTube
friend of mine named splice do you guys
probably already are familiar with he
made a video about how to save the steel
how to save some steel when you buy
these mythic outfits they come with a
bundle which we're gonna be talking
about a little bit later in this video
but if you want you can either click the
I on the top right if it shows up or in
the description if you want to save
yourself some steel and get those
effects definitely go check out his
video like I said in the description
tell them I sent you and now let's
continue on so next up is the extra
steel fest for this weekend you're going
to get twice the more steel and all
completed orders and contracts and
received a 50% steal at the end of every
match like I said it's going to be for
the weekend so if you need some extra
steel probably to go get the new mythic
outfits definitely want to hop on board
and plays and watch as you can this
weekend one quick tip that the
developers did say and I also do
recommend this definitely want to save
your contract orders from today because
the double xp does not start until
tomorrow so if you're watching this on
Thursday definitely save up your
contract orders for tomorrow so that you
can get double steel next is going to be
a community order but it's a little bit
of a different one this time the
factions are going a head-to-head in
this one now instead of us working
together we're gonna be fighting each
other basically it's going to be called
predator and prey and you have to be the
first faction to perform the highest
amount of executions during the weekend
and the winner will get some steel and
some emblem rewards and as well these
rewards are also going to be affected by
the double xp event so the rewards are
actually doubled so to recap first place
is probably going to be getting 3,000
second place is going to get 2,000 and
third place will get 1,000 because of
the double xp event next up is the new
bundle it's gonna be called the
celebration bundle and it's a limited
time bundle which instantly unlocks the
three special items for your hero that
being the new mythic outfits I just
showed and the two emotes that we had
last week which is the drinking and the
salty mode this is available from until
March 12th includes the house champion
outfit the rub salt in the wound emo and
the down the hatch emote which I just
stated the cost is going to be 25,000
steel and it dynamically adjust the
price depending on what you already have
so say for example I have both the
emotes and all I need is the house
champion outfit the bundle isn't going
to be 25
thousand it's going to be a little bit
less expensive than that because they
don't want to have you pay double for
the same stuff and then a few bits of
other info that they released at the end
of the stream is that they are on the
very last stages for console dedicated
servers if you already don't know PC RT
has dedicated servers but console
players do not like myself we are
hopefully going to be getting that very
soon they said because they're on the
last stage of testing it so hopefully
within the next couple of weeks we may
receive it for once and then lastly to
end is the message to all the afk
farmers from the devs basically they're
saying if you start the afk from and
you're reported for it and caught you're
gonna be getting a three-day bin plus a
warning to not afk again and then if you
do it in it then if you do continue to
do the afk farming after the 3-day Ben
they're gonna give you a 10-day bin and
then they're gonna reset your profile
all your reps and all your steel is
gonna go out the window and you're gonna
be set back at zero as well as having a
10-day bin so definitely do not want to
afk farm because that's depending on the
person you are you may have put a lot of
work into your character so definitely
don't afk farm and that's going to be it
guys hope you guys didn't enjoy this
very short video I apologize there
wasn't really much info but there was
still a few things that we wanted to
talk about maybe next week we'll be
getting some more info who knows but
with that guys hope you guys did enjoy
the video elective if you did enjoy
subscribe if you're new I post a lot of
four on our content I do news discussion
leaks the informational site a foreigner
I like to cover a lot my two most recent
videos are gonna be on screen if you
guys did missed those definitely wanna
go check those out if you didn't and
that guys hope you have a great rest
your day and peace out